Cuáles son las implicaciones de esta ley
Marcial en estos territorios ocupados ya
ayer Putin afirmó y dio más poderes a
los gobernantes de estas zonas
correcto jugar bueno Muchas gracias por
la invitación pues efectivamente como tú
bien has dicho el 30 de septiembre el
gobierno Vladimir Putin anezó las zonas
o regiones de Luján
y saborilla con la digamos la condena
internacional justamente debido a esas
medidas y lo que ha anunciado el día de
hoy habrá Putin es asumir la ley Marcial
que finalmente dar o tomar posesión de
control militar de las zonas con el
propósito también de hacer una contra
ofensiva lo que viene siendo un
contraataque ucraniano con el objetivo
de recuperar estas zonas ya anexadas
ilegalmente por la comunidad
internacional de parte de Rusia
la situación es compleja lo que
evidenciamos es que vienen siendo ya 8 a
10 meses de guerra en los que
definitivamente Putin debió y su
gobierno seguramente estimar que esto
debía ser más bien un blitzcript una
Guerra Relámpago y claramente al no
haber llevado esto conclusión y el
gobierno ucraniano tomando ciertas
medidas de control ofensiva esto ha
llevado al gobierno ruso a tomar ciertas
medidas de excepción que claro si bien
el gobierno ucraniano en las viene
llevando desde febrero que se inició la
Guerra la ley Marcial ahora Rusia lo
está haciendo con el propósito de
generar cierta situación de emergencia y
porque no también evacuar a 60.000
ciudadanos de estas zonas de conflicto
para evitar mayores muertes o daños a su
población de parte también de lo que
viene siendo la contra ofensivo craneal
Sí precisamente bajo esa excusa de una
inminente ataque sobre gerson Rusia
estaba cuando a cientos de miles de
civiles pero Ucrania dice que estos son
deportaciones que sabemos de ese proceso
Bueno en realidad lo que estamos
identificando en este contexto es que
tenemos ambos lados diciendo una verdad
una verdad distinta verdad estamos una
situación de guerra en la que hay
propaganda de ambos lados lo que he
identificado la comunidad internacional
es que lo que estamos viendo Es una
población que está haciendo
Aparentemente de acuerdo a lo que
indican distintas Fuentes acosada
atormentada por el gobierno ruso que de
hecho es lo que ha conducido también es
un momento a votaciones de referéndum
que según indican las fuentes ucranianas
pero también algunas otras fuentes
internacionales corresponderían a
votaciones
fraguadas o digamos fraudulentas a
partir de la coerción O el acoso que las
fuerzas militares rusas estarían
llevando o conduciendo
a digamos
afectación de esta población en zona de
conflicto en otro tema La estrategia de
Rusia en este momento consiste en
golpear la estructura eléctrica de
Ucrania de cara al invierno ese es un
crimen de guerra
pues definitivamente estamos viendo una
situación crítica estamos viendo que ya
han habido 300 ataques a centrales
energéticas ucranianas por parte del
gobierno ruso Rusia claramente está
buscando asfixiar de gas digamos a
Europa quiere quitarle gas a Europa para
condicionarla seguramente en tanto hay
muchas sanciones y medidas que Europa y
por supuesto Ucrania vienen conduciendo
contra el gobierno Ruso y
definitivamente es una acción en
particular hablando del caso ucraniano
que busca al estilo de la del de los
asedios de Las Guerras más antiguas
asfixiar a votar al pueblo ucraniano y
matarlo en frío definitivamente es una
acción condenable y que a todas luces
muestra una una intención de llevar a
final de concluir esta guerra a toda
marcha o a toda Costa Y eso es algo que
no podemos tolerar